pensons aux nordistes de l'air anxieuse
et à ses 10 ans contracté un sombre
pourquoi c'est bien facile à deviner
c'est évidemment parce que l'olympien
approche à grands pas voilà l'olympia
c'est la consécration n'est pas une
fanatique quand même de la chanson du
music hall j'ai l'impression à moi vous
conter mais alors oui le même titre que
ça qui m'intéresse c'est parce que je
mets un an ou deux ans et puis après
malgré tout c'est pas un métier toute
une vie pour une fille de 20 ans de la
chanter oui ça peut être un métier toute
une vie et des gens qui n'ont fait que
ça toute leur vie mais je pense que
maintenant ça devient de plus en plus
difficile parce que il ya de plus en
plus de concurrence
alors il faut vraiment être très très
solide pour tenir et je crois pas que ce
soit très solide
croyez vous n'êtes pas très solide
pourquoi là on parce que je pense que
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance ça ça repose
pas sur
ça repose si vous voulez sur des
chansons qui sont pas mal en face à ses
côtés des chansons géniales sapologie
dans la publicité peut-être pas
tellement la publicité car sa carrière
en annoncer quand même un petit peu
rapide arrivée à être enfin je leur dis
au bout d'un an je ne trouvais pas à moi
je trouve que c'est râpé sur un tour
rapide parce que c'est pas un an qu'on
peut arriver à un point de métier pour
avant
voyez il ya des enjeux choquait pas du
tout il ya beaucoup de
le chanteur d'artistes qui avant que sa
marge ont travaillé beaucoup sur les
planches du cabaret show comme ça comme
moi jamais est ce que c'est vous qui
menez votre carrière ou est-ce que vous
êtes tributaire d'un imprésario des
maisons de disques mais dans l'édition
qui vous force à certaines telles choses
oui de toute façon dès qu'on fait ce
métier on est toujours très du terme ce
que vous venez vous enfin je crois que
malheureusement ou heureusement enfin je
suis un peu laissé à moi même
nous tous ici devant le même
je veux
nous vivons pour l'instant jour le jour
mais pas vrai j'ai d'avant
nous vivons père de prendre un autre
tour si jusqu alors
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
toi qui l'attend encore toi c'est du
bien
que là
repas tout cela vous choque
on peut savoir comment sera demain
hamon
je voulais
c'est aujourd'hui sous toit
on réserve
insouciance et de rêves associant danse
d'un instant
combien de temps cela va-t-il durer
peut-être comme moi de demain
tu fous
que serais-je dans quelques
que serait janvier
puzzle
que serait en quelque
je n'ai